les étudiants qui restent mobilisés et
qui continue aussi de faire vivre leur
association c'est le cas on va le voir
avec margot boissarie bonjour bonjour
vous êtes étudiante en 3e année
aeronautica à l'estaca sur le campus de
saint quentin en yvelines vous est
également la présidente de l'association
étudiante
estac modélisme vous allez nous en
parlait tout à l'heure qui a dû à
notamment annulé une course de drones
qui était prévu dans l'est dans les
prochains jours déjà
parlez nous de votre expérience
personnelle de confinement vous êtes
vous originaire de la région bordelaise
vous êtes retourné dans cette région
bordelaise pendant ce confinement
comment ça se passe pour vous on va
écouter je continue à suivre mes cours
je m'occupe comme je peux j'ai commandé
des puzzles je suis une maquette d'avion
je m'occupe du jardin les faire des
courses quand c'est nécessaire je sors
le moins possible et voilà je regarde un
peu la télé j'arrive à mon côté ça va
donc on cherche à s'occuper pendant
cette semaine je me dis vous êtes vous à
l'estaca présidente également plus être
être étudiante vous êtes présidente
d'une association étudiante qui
s'appelle estaca modélisme est ce que
vous continuez ce rôle à distance ce
rôle de présidente de l'association
estac à modélisme alors pour l'instant
ce début de confinement
on s'occupe des événements qui ont été
habillés comme vous l'avez dit
précédemment on a dû annuler notre
course annuelle de drones donc c'est ça
s'appelle l'estacade renard est donc
cette année c'était l'édition numéro 4
ça se passe si une course de drones qui
se passe d'un parking souterrain de
l'école tous les ans est donc cette
année celle de l'espace et le 17 et 18
avril nous avions créé une nouvelle
course qui était réservé aux étudiants
donc au s'occupe de recontacter tout
tous les pilotes qui s'étaient inscrits
l'entreprise de chronométrage que nous
allions nous contacter et donc on annule
tout ça en leur alors promettant une
prochaine édition l'année prochaine
aussi on avait une événement avec
donc avec le décès l'association de
modélisme de laval car l'estac à deux
campus saint quentin en yvelines
on avait une rencontre prévue la semaine
dernière sur deux jours on a dû
l'annuler on avait défait des commandes
de matériel et du coup on va sûrement la
reporter en septembre nokia non c'est
presqu'autant de travail pour organiser
que pour désorganiser pour annuler tout
ça c'est ça oui car on essaye de garder
des bons contacts avec les personnes que
nous avons contactés pour pouvoir
réitérer l'expérience l'année prochaine
donc ça c'est pour votre association
vous êtes aussi avant d'être président
d'une association étudiante je le disais
en 3e année aéronautique à l'estaca sur
le campus de saint quentin en yvelines
comment vous maintenez le lien avec vos
autres camarades est ce que vous
continuez de suivre malgré tout des
cours à distance
alors oui on a commencé ce matin à 8h30
j'avais cours de mode de propulsion donc
l'école a décidé d'utiliser la
plateforme microsoft ims pour nos cours
cela fonctionne très bien moi j'ai très
bien mais j'ai vu j'ai pu suivre
parfaitement mon cours ce matin après
les la semaine dernière on n'a pas du
tout court car l'équipe pédagogique a
tenu à nous offrir une des méthodes qui
ont été mises au point qui ont qui
fonctionne en fait ils ont voulu
vérifier si tout cela fonctionnait si
les profs étaient présents ils ont
adapté notre emploi du temps donc ils
ont travaillé la semaine dernière à tout
cela est donc cette année on peut
accéder cette semaine on peut accéder à
des cours bien bien mise en place de
plus nous on a des projets en cours
on doit continuer pendant confinement
car on a des rendus de projets à faire
donc on communique par messenger avec
nos groupes de projets par
visioconférence sur mm sur messenger et
ça fonctionne très bien on utilise aussi
team ce camp ça peut quand ça peut quand
ça peut se faire
et on continue nos projets on a installé
aussi la wii l'école nous a mis à
disposition les licences pour les
logiciels qu'on doit utiliser nous en
misant pour mes mises à disposition
plein de tutoriels pour la mise en place
de ces logiciels sur nos ordinateurs
donc on a compris un les choses qui
continuent de s'organiser malgré tout à
distance merci margot boissard us avec
plaisir mais bon courage à vous je
rappelle que
vous êtes étudiant à l'estaca et
présidente de l'association étudiante
estaca modélisme
merci à vous